[Music]
they fought armored vehicles driven off
cliffs and chowed down in tokyo
now after eight movies they're out of
ideas and we'll do all that again
[Music]
plus go to space you said they should go
to space so they did a little space as a
treat two dudes from the ghetto
outer space
fast nine
after corona put their coronas on ice
for a while our favorite family films
have returned just like a family now we
became a family it's for family family
family family and it's got everything
you'd expect from a new fest almond fake
deaths
pretty nifty magic trick some doomsday
device a prop guy picked up at target
what the hell is this and the annual
reveal of a new secret family member i'm
here for the team that crippled my
brother you didn't even know you had a
kid that is my sister i miss my baby boy
jacob is dom's brother how many
relatives are these people hiding 10
bucks says letty has an evil twin by f11
i'm sorry i'm sorry i am sorry
prepare to go back in time and learn all
about dom's secret brother from another
mother
and possibly father truly the only clue
they related is the dramatic look back
and the mid scene grip flex
[Music]
they got that one from their dad
john cena stars as dom's scorn brother
jacob who went from mechanic to super
spy before it was cool and now that vin
has finished teaching the rock how to
act he's found a more submissive
wrestler who knows where he stands in
the pecking order i had to earn my way
in and i'm very grateful for that and
bravo in that choice ben cena won't
cause any trouble you can't see him and
he can't see taiwan
uh
[Music]
when jacob has a fiendish plan to steal
the magic salad bowl that charlize
theron uses to cut her hair all your
favorites will return to stop them with
one glaring exception
and one small exception you probably
didn't notice
there's dom who's been practicing extra
hard on his driving face
thinking face
driving face
thinking face hmm
mia who picked up hacking and kung fu by
osmosis i think i can link into their
feed letty who doesn't hesitate to pawn
her stepson off on dom who doesn't
hesitate to pawn his own son off on mia
who doesn't hesitate to pawn her nephew
off on brian poor little hot potato the
tokyo drifters who spent their time off
screen getting an online degree in
rocket science
these former rivals who've become an old
married couple so tootsie rolls is space
food
cause that's all you ate it's fat free
bro their former love interest who's
become a third wheel helen mirren who
has more sexual chemistry in five
minutes with dom than he has with
michelle rodriguez in the whole
franchise you're my favorite american
cipher the mysterious hacker who can
mysteriously change her clothes do her
makeup and take a dump in an empty
transparent cell and as the trailer
spoiled the return of han
why because fans want justice how well
um
uh
let's see
okay
right right okay sure got it and now i'm
bored hit the nos again
this story is sick
hit that vape until f9's action scenes
start to make sense where cars can
outrun the landmines they drive over zip
lines go on for infinity
[Music]
magnets affect every car except the one
with a giant magnet on it and leaving
orbit in a pontiac figuero doesn't
immediately catch fire collapse and
explode when they crash into a satellite
at 17 000 miles per hour
look i'm not asking for realism but the
intro to homeboys in outer space tried
harder
six seasons in a movie
so resign yourself to what these films
have become no longer earnest action
flicks about street racing or so dumb
their brilliant heist movies no the
franchise that was good then bad then so
bad it's good has reached its final form
so bad but they think if they admit it
you'll think it's good we've taken out
cars trains tanks i'm not gonna even
mention the submarine and i ain't got
one single scar to show for you got a
brother who also happens to be some kind
of super spy who pre-planned an aerial
jump and landed at the bottom of an
airplane mexico
no way
no way you know ain't nobody gonna
believe us right
you're right this was a movie this would
be the moment where the villain has an
unexpected setback oh no the franchise
has become self-aware quick someone toss
it to corona
starring even more
car
puns
the last wrench hunter
john scenic root michelin rodriguez
gran therese bros
ludacrash grow manual transmission
charlize trade in
mr no body shop
han in 60 seconds
auto okay that was just too easy dodge
ramsay aston mirren
mia sorrento
and car db
car wars episode 9 the phantom menace
pretty sad this is the last good thing
universal's got going for it enjoy these
before fast 10 has him driving through
jurassic park to fight the boss baby
you've heard the stories of vin diesel
and the raw count each hit in their
fight scenes to make sure neither one
looks like a loser well we ran the
numbers for every fight scene they've
ever done to find out who kicked the
most ass over their entire career click
on the box on the right to settle this
large veiny feud once and for all
go ahead skin it skin that smoke wagon
and see what happens
a really dumb movie about really dumb
people doing really dumb things for
really dumb reasons
there's 104 days of summer vacation
and school comes along just to end it
don't have a good day have a great day